bordeaux et faudra vous la baliser les
lots 6
du bonheur du plaisir d'aller à la
rencontre des gens
peu en fait
par jp recommandent entre un stage alors
j'aimerais lire plus
la sienne poser la chambre de giovanni
james baldwin
pourquoi j'aime autant et un moment sur
les hommes incapables d'aimer
malheureusement je pense que je connais
la réponse
ce que je suis en train de faire
on crée toujours un lecteur de musique
je pense pas que j en écoutant de la
musique ce que oui si je ne faisais pas
mais d'avoir danger tecsys est un
problème ou le problème non mais j'étais
mauvais élèves
je suis sans mes devoirs j'arrivais
toujours par monts colonies gars
passionné par toutes sortes
moi j'ai l'écriture et les gens qui
naissent avec une place dans la dans
l'amendement la société puisse ou c'est
gagné d'avancé
les gens qui se cherchent des gens qui
cherchent à faire cette place qui la
créent eux mêmes ou qui se la font
donner ou évidemment
il ya des gens qui sont en position de
je peux en vigueur de faiblesse mais
ils sont pas en position d'autorité et m
jeune homosexuel me sens plus près d'une
femme
à qui on refuse un de ses draps qui on
refuse l'égalité à qui on refuse une
position une parole une liberté que
un homme hétéro de 30 ans qui nous dit
quoi faire puis qui
donc c'est ça tu veux dire quand je dis
que je me semble très proche des femmes
[Musique]
tandis que je suis rarement à l'avant
d'une grande foule ou d'une grande salle
donc c'est vraiment qu'ils sont toujours
un peu intimidant mais qui sont très
inspirant ce quand j'entends ce genre
d'histoire où ce genre de confidences de
la part d'eads et les gens du public qui
parlent de leur commune ya tout qui
m'écrivent ils écrivent aussi pour m'en
parler
elle fait toujours très plaisir
évidemment formule 6ème visibilité
l'idée c'est que c'est que les gens
puissent se voir à l'écran puisse voir
une représentation de boncourt était
petit j'ai passé beaucoup de temps à
temps des signes puis à les aimer a aimé
les hyéro livres et héroïne les délais
qui tombaient les personnages principaux
mais sans jamais vraiment revoir le
genre d'amour le genre de drame ans ou
de sexualité que moi je viens de vivre
jeudi film à travers lequel on cherche
je trouve ça fun réponse forme échappe
certains autres donc nous avons dû jeu
je me comprends
salle qu'une
je me satan
on est là
je pense pas que je parle juste une
génération je pense que je parle j'ai
l'âge que j'ai quand je fais des films
que je fais c'est sûr c'est factuel et
moi je pense pas que je parle d'une
génération je pense que je parle de
l'amour puis de la différence
puis si ça concerne tout le monde
[Musique]